[Música]
hablamos de nicaragua el presidente y
candidato a la reelección de ese país en
el ortega venció por quinta vez en las
urnas tras obtener el 74 punto 99 por
ciento de los votos en unas elecciones
en las que la oposición fue la gran
ausente
ortega estará al mando del país para su
cuarto mandato consecutivo tras impedir
la participación de sus principales
rivales la oposición considera estas
elecciones como fraudulentas mientras
que la comunidad internacional afirma
que carecen de legitimidad el presidente
de eeuu joe biden en calificó el proceso
de farsa y por su parte la unión europea
aseguró que la administración de ortega
es un régimen autocrático
mientras que rusia dijo que era
inaceptable el llamado de países
occidentales a rechazar estos resultados
vamos a ver entonces qué pasa en
nicaragua con nuestro primer invitado el
día el extenso helguera cio de la
encuestadora y más solo analista
político y también ha sido veedor
internacional en elecciones pasadas
censo gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo américa bueno
de estas elecciones de nicaragua y por
qué son tan cuestionadas además que no
hubo ninguna presencia de veedores
internacionales
justamente iba a apuntar en esto uno de
los requisitos que la democracia moderna
en las actuales elecciones
tiene es que las elecciones sean
abiertas lo más transparentes posibles y
justos e invitan a veedores
internacionales
pero aquí lo que se hizo es invitar no a
a ciertos amigos probablemente
simpatizantes del régimen para que
vengan a hacer rededores y no se abrió
las puertas a las instituciones
internacionales
como es lo usual
fuera de según algunas organizaciones
haber registrado aproximadamente
200 hechos de violencia política en
donde los representantes de los partidos
políticos no los dejaron acercarse a las
mesas de votación para poder disfrutar
el voto plagado evidentemente de la
del encarcelamiento y de la persecución
política a siete de los principales
candidatos opositores que tenía el
régimen más cercano con posibilidad que
evidentemente lo puedan derrotar en las
normas electorales
ahora eso le quiero preguntar si tras
esta negativa
ortega teme algo o simplemente no le
importa las opiniones que pueda emitir
la comunidad internacional y con todo
este panorama le pregunto si podemos
esperar algún tipo de cambio en este
cuarto mandato consecutivo de daniel
ortega o todo va a seguir igual
bueno de pronto yo considero que todo va
a seguir igual porque el régimen en el
cual él ha estado manteniendo se le ha
funcionado
actualmente hay represión por parte
siquiera de cualquier tipo de protestas
que puedan realizarse en este país
además que es la única manifestación
digamos importante se puede dar en costa
rica en donde hubieron alrededor de 1000
personas haciendo las marchas pero la
persecución política y la la la el
acusar de terrorismo a cualquier tipo de
protesta o cualquier tipo de acción
política en contra del régimen fue a
agarrar y obviamente a enmarcar
este tipo de situaciones en donde
politizamos cualquier actividad
democrática que se en contra del
presidente esto le ha funcionado y tiene
controladas las elecciones además
y la mayor parte de representación en
los poderes del estado y en las
instituciones con personas afines al
gobierno
esto hace tener un control de la
institucionalidad y que la democracia no
tenga ese balance de poderes que si
tienen otros países así que de momento
considero que va a continuar salvo que
haya algún tipo de protesta masiva
quizás allí puede hacer alguna variación
mucho más dura de lo que ya tiene
sometido al país en su usted lo decía
muy bien hablaba de costa rica- la
vecina costa rica donde hay un gran
número de opositores exiliados
nicaragüenses en ese país hablando
entonces de la oposición le quería
preguntar qué va a pasar con la
oposición con los opositores detenidos y
también con los que están en el exilio
ellos pudieran también hacer
vos digamos eco de lo que pasa en
nicaragua para ejercer también algún
tipo de presión dentro del régimen
ortega
si definitivamente va a depender del
activismo de la oposición que sin
embargo está o diezmado por está por
este encarcelamiento de estas siete
personas ya había una encuesta en donde
a mediados del año solamente le daba el
14 o el 15 por ciento de favoritismo al
actual régimen si es que se hubiesen
enfrentado otros candidatos políticos
que evidentemente se encontraban o
terminaron presos entonces la oposición
va a tener que tener un rol fundamental
y un liderazgo importante y quizás allá
desde costa rica porque es el único país
en donde ellos podrían tener las
garantías sin embargo ante la ausencia
no solamente de liderazgo sino de la
comunicación política que va a tener que
darse a nivel internacional se va a
poder quizás
pero frenos o poner a la luz pública en
acciones que de momento el gobierno lo
va a tener sin cuidado eso ya para
finalizar le quería preguntar entonces
ya que tocaba también la comunidad
internacional se pueden esperar más
sanciones por parte de esta comunidad
internacional los países que pues no le
agrada el régimen de ortega para su
gobierno sea más acciones por parte de
la comunidad como eeuu para su para el
gobierno ortega y también le preguntó
por el futuro de nicaragua que podemos
esperar entonces
bueno de hecho eeuu ha dicho que va a
utilizar todas las medidas de represión
no solamente a nivel político de la
comunidad internacional sino también
económicas entonces
a esto también la unión europea y otras
instituciones se van a sumar para
ejercer presión porque es lo que queda
de cara a la comunidad internacional
esto evidentemente va a complicar la
situación de nicaragua la va a colocar
en un tema de las relaciones
internacionales bastante complejo
probablemente lo vaya a evocar oa
trasladar a un régimen de víctimas de
victimización por parte del presidente
porque va es lo único que le queda no va
admitir error no va a renunciar al
gobierno y la presión para la población
de nicaragua sobre todo
serna que se va a encontrar de una
manera mucho más complicada en su vida
cotidiana y probablemente también en la
recepción el traslado de el dinero que
pueda hacer la población desde el
exterior hacia ellos y finalmente esto
puede ser un elemento de protesta social
y ciudad